[APPLAUSE]
BEN RAWLENCE: Thanks
very much for having me.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I'd like to tell you
about this refugee
camp called Dadaab, which is
the City of Thorns of the title.
I spent four years
going to that camp,
following a range of
people who live there.
Nine, whose lives are
documented in the book.
And the book talks about
their ups, their downs,
their lives in this very
strange, limbo place.
So I'll just pause for a minute
and let a couple of people
sit down.
OK.
So to get an idea of Dadaab,
what I'd like you to do
is to imagine a city of
half a million people.
That's about the size of
metropolitan New Orleans,
or Zurich, or Bristol in the UK.
And imagine a city like that
with no permanent structures,
with no sewage facilities,
with no running water,
with no sanitation, with no
proper roads, with no power.
And imagine that
those people are not
allowed to leave the city.
And imagine that they're
not allowed to work.
What would that look like?
And the answer is it
looks a bit like this.
It's stuck in the
middle of the desert.
There are thorn
bushes all around.
And after a couple of years,
when your tent disintegrates--
that you've been
given by the UN--
you're forced to cut
some of those thorn trees
down and make a little
house to live in.
Because in the middle
of the dry season,
it gets up to about 45
degrees centigrade, which
is 105, 110 degrees Fahrenheit.
It's very hot.
And in the rainy
season, of course,
the whole place
pretty much floats.
Because this flat plain on
bedrock made of dust and mud,
when the rainy season comes,
all of that has nowhere to go.
So everybody pretty
much drowns in water.
And at the moment there is a
cholera epidemic in the camp,
because every rainy season
without the sanitation,
the disease just licks through
the camp like wildfire.
The way that people
survive in the camp
is through food rations,
which all of us,
through our tax dollars
contribute to the United
Nations, pay for.
And those food rations are
distributed every two weeks.
And they constitute a portion of
rice, maybe some sorghum, maybe
some maize, maybe some beans,
and a little bit of oil.
It's around 2,000
calories, which
are finely balanced
and finely costed.
And the World Food Programme
distributes that to everybody.
This city has been
there for 25 years.
There have been people eating
those rations for 25 years.
And they've never left.
There are now
three generations--
two generations of people
who have been born there.
So some people
came in the 1990s,
when the camp was
originally established
after the Somali civil war,
and their children have now
had children.
So you have whole
generations that
have grown up without ever
seeing any other horizon.
I'd like to tell you the story
of one man in particular.
One of these nine who
I interviewed there
over the course of
four years while doing
the research for this book.
And he's a young
man called Guled.
He's now just over 20 years old.
When I met him, he was 17.
And he was born in
Mogadishu in 1993,
about the time that
Black Hawk Down happened.
Those two American helicopters
that were shot down
in Mogadishu, which
brought to an end
the Bush/Clinton-sponsored
intervention in Somalia.
And after that, the US left.
The UN left.
And Somalia pretty much had
no government up until now.
So Guled was born then.
So his life is a
very interesting arc,
which pretty much mirrors
the collapse of Somalia,
and the rise of
this refugee camp.
He grew up in Mogadishu.
He scrambled around.
He lost his parents.
He found a living,
one way or another.
And interestingly,
throughout this war,
he kept going to school.
He kept going to a small
primary school in Mogadishu.
And one day in 2010, in the
middle of the war-- every day
there's bombs going off.
He's taking a different
route to get to school.
And one day he goes to school,
and a couple of pickup trucks
show up, full of
al-Shabaab militants.
Al-Shabaab is
allied to al-Qaeda.
It's an extremist radical group.
And at that point, they
controlled about 80%
of Somalia.
Now they control a bit less,
but they're still a big force.
So one day he's in class.
These guys pitch up at
the back of the classroom.
He looks at the teacher.
He sees the teacher freeze.
He knows something's up.
He turns around, and he sees
these seven guys in the room.
They take all of the
tallest boys in the class.
They blindfold them.
They put them in a pickup truck.
And they take them
to a training camp.
For a month, he's
in a training camp.
And he is being taught
to recite the Quran.
He's being taught how
to handle a weapon.
He's being taught
to-- eventually,
he's assigned to something
called the hisbat, which
is the police.
The morality police
that al-Shabaab
used to make sure that the
people in the areas that they
control are abiding by the
Sharia law that they espouse.
The elite group is called
the [ARABIC], which
is the suicide bombing group.
And some of the kids, of course,
wanted to join that group.
The ones who had volunteered.
But the conscripts-- the
people who had been kidnapped,
like him-- were
assigned to the hisbat.
So he was then he was then
sent out on these patrols
to police in Mogadishu.
After around a month,
he managed to escape.
And he had-- funnily enough
for a 16-year-old kid--
he had a wife.
Because in the
war, life is short.
And as a result of that,
people are increasingly
marrying younger and
younger and younger.
And it's something we see in
poor and conservative societies
all over the world-- very,
very young marriages.
He had a wife.
When he escaped, he was too
scared to go to his wife.
Because he was worried that
al-Shabaab would follow him
and would punish
the wife as well.
So he called her.
He said, I'm running away to
Kenya, to the refugee camps.
And he left without seeing her.
He got to the camp, after
this very long journey.
He had no money when he arrived.
He had one guy that he
knew who lived there.
And through a complete
stroke of luck,
he managed to find that guy.
And that guy showed him
how the camp worked.
He took him into his house.
He lived with this
friend of his,
called Noor, who's
also 16, 17 years old.
And Noor showed him
how the rations work.
Showed him how to
get his ration card.
How to register with the UN.
He showed him how
to try and work.
Because after all of this time--
after making this journey,
getting to the camp,
living with Noor--
what Guled really wanted
to do was to phone his wife
and to tell her where he was.
And to see how she was
doing, because still there's
a war going on in Mogadishu.
He wanted to see
what was going on.
But the principle challenge
of the refugee camp
is how to get cash.
Because this is an
economy that operates
pretty much without money.
He was surviving
on the food rations
that his friend had been given.
But his friend
didn't have a job.
He couldn't get
any money, either.
So in order to make a
phone call to his wife
to tell her where he was,
the first day that he
got his ration card.
Went to collect his food
rations from the United Nations.
He goes outside.
He sells the rations for $2.
Those $2 allow him to
go to the phone shop
in the market to make a
phone call to tell his wife,
I'm here in the refugee camp.
I'm OK.
He starts telling Maryam,
his wife, what it's like.
There's food.
There's shelter.
There's peace.
He's heard that maybe there's
the possibility of getting
resettled to the United States.
Maryam thinks, that
sounds quite good.
The war here is pretty bad.
I want to come.
He says, great.
Great.
You can come.
She says, but I don't
have the fare for the bus
to get from Mogadishu to Kenya,
which is around 400 miles.
You've got to send
money so I can come.
So now he has another challenge.
How does he get money to send
to Maryam to bring her there?
As I said, there's
no money in the camp.
People can't work.
There are no jobs.
Everyone's surviving
on these rations.
So he tries his
hand at portering.
There's a black market.
As you'd expect,
an informal city
like this-- after 25 years,
a black market has emerged.
There are some shops.
There are buses.
There are trucks.
There are things going on.
There are phone shops.
But he, of course,
is a new arrival.
He's not part of that.
So he starts trying
to do a portering job.
He tries to carry rations
from the distribution site
on behalf of women,
family members who
are not very strong, who can't
carry these big sacks of food.
But of course, he
can't lift them.
He's small.
He's a young guy.
He's desperately trying to
pick up these big sacks so
that he can earn $50, so that
he can pay the fare of his wife
to come.
To cut a long story short,
he doesn't raise the money.
In the end, she borrows
the money in Mogadishu.
She comes and joins
him in the camp.
And it turns out,
she's pregnant.
These two young people-- 17
years old, 18 years old--
embark on a new life
now in the refugee camp.
He's told her all
these wonderful things
about how it's safe, and
how there's food, and so on.
When she gets there, she has a
very different take on things.
It's really hot.
She's pregnant.
She wants juice.
She wants fruit.
None of these things
are available.
She's living in this
crappy stick house.
She used to live in a
concrete house in Mogadishu.
The principal complaint that
I heard over and over again
from Maryam is, at least we had
a washing machine in Mogadishu!
In Dadaab, water's scarce.
You have to line up
with 100 other people
to wait your turn at the tap
with your big yellow issued
jerrycan just to get the water.
So they have a very
difficult time.
Fast forward now four years.
In the book is the story
of Maryam and Guled,
and how they
struggled in the camp.
And how that struggle put
pressure on their marriage.
And all of the different
things that emerged from that.
But I'd just like to take you
up to the end of that story,
where after a famine; after
the Kenyan military invaded
Somalia; after the breakdown
of law and order in the camp;
after police operations in
the camp, beating people up.
Guled running for his life from
the police again-- in Kenya
this time, not from
al-Shabaab in Somalia.
After all of these ups and
downs, we get to early 2015.
Guled and Maryam by now
have had two children,
and there's another
one on the way.
And Guled is terrified
of going back to Somalia.
He can't go back to Somalia.
The UN has just started
voluntary repatriation
back to Somalia, after
a lot of pressure
from Kenya trying to push
these refugees back home again.
Maryam thinks, finally.
Yeah.
This is a good idea.
We can go.
We can go back now.
But for Guled,
that's not an option.
He was kidnapped.
He remembers those
guys in black.
He remembers that fear.
He's worried about the
revenge from these people.
So they're a bit stuck.
They don't really
know what to do.
They're having a
crisis in their family.
But Guled, this
dilemma that he's in,
precisely encapsulates
the dilemma
that everybody in
the camp is facing.
Because after 25
years, you're supposed
to have some kind of solution.
Some kind of future.
Some kind of hope for your life.
But he can't go back to Somalia.
He can't go down into
Kenya to claim asylum
in Kenya, because Kenya has a
road block south of the camp.
It doesn't let anybody
go into Kenya proper.
And there are no slots
for resettlement abroad.
And this is the crux of our
current global refugee problem.
That once upon a time, you
went to a refugee camp.
It was a temporary thing.
And while you were there,
the rich nations in the world
would relocate, would
take quotas of people who
needed a safe place to stay.
And the refugee burden
would be shared.
But we've got to
such a point now,
because that pipeline has
shrunk and shrunk and narrowed
and narrowed.
And the rich countries
don't want refugees.
They certainly don't
want Muslim refugees,
because of the
Islamophobia that has
been a feature of modern, rich
societies ever since 9/11.
That quota has got
smaller and smaller.
And as that quota has
got smaller and smaller,
these refugee camp populations
have grown and grown and grown.
And there are many, many people
like Guled, who are simply
stuck in these very, very
difficult domestic scenarios,
trying to-- as you can
imagine, refugee life
puts incredible
pressure on a family.
The difficulties for
the kids growing up
with very, very small
opportunities for them
to go to school.
With all of the
health problems that I
talked about-- malnutrition,
cholera, and so on.
So this refugee
system is broken.
And I'll talk a little bit
later about ways in which we
could think about fixing it.
But for Guled, I left him
at the beginning of 2015.
At the last chapter or
the end of this book,
I left him wrestling
with the idea of Europe.
And this is why Europe, for
people in sub-Saharan Africa,
is some kind of solution.
Or at least a dream
of a solution,
even though it's
expensive, even though it's
dangerous and difficult.
So he has no money, but he's
sitting with his friends
in the camp.
And he gets-- all of these
guys are in a football team.
They're all friends
with each other--
they get a phone call from
one of their teammates
who made it to Italy.
Who spent probably
around $10,000
to get to Italy on one
of those leaky boats.
And he phones back to the
refugee camp and says,
you got to come!
It's great!
There's work.
I'll send you money,
so you can come, too.
And he's selling them
this idea, even if it's
not quite as he's painting it.
That's the image
that's coming down
the phone line, that's getting
all these guys energized.
And for somebody like Guled, who
wants to look after his family,
he wants some kind of future.
He wants a chance to work.
Europe represents this
crazy idea of hope, at least
some kind of future when
you can't go anywhere else.
You can't go back to Somalia.
Staying in the camp is
completely miserable.
So when I left him, that
was the dilemma he was in.
That was the situation
he was stuck in.
Do I go to Europe without
money and try and blag my way?
Try and find some route
through Sudan, through Darfur,
through the Sahara, into Libya,
up onto the coast to Benghazi
or places like that-- Misurata--
and then across to Italy?
Or do I stick it
out in the camp?
See how I go.
Meanwhile, the food rations
have been cut by 30%,
because the UN has a crisis
with funding for Syria.
So people in Dadaab are going
hungry, because there's not
enough food to eat.
Like I said, his
kids now are going
to have to fight for a
place at primary school.
There's cholera.
It's not a good situation.
I recently checked
Guled's Facebook profile.
And on it, it says
he's from Ghana,
and he recently
visited Paris, France.
And there's a photo of him.
His face Photoshopped
onto the body
of Wayne Rooney, the player
for Manchester United,
because he's a big Man U fan.
And his whole feed
on Facebook is
about Manchester United, and
pictures of Man U players,
and so on.
He's living an
imaginary life online,
that is unavailable
to him in reality.
And if you look at a
lot of his friends,
a lot of the other people
I know in the camp--
they're all doing it.
You see people from Cincinnati,
Ohio; from Athens, Georgia;
from Stockholm, Sweden.
And you see them in
front of the Eiffel
Tower in all these nice
clothes that they don't own.
But they've pasted their own
face on to these other images.
So they're trying to lay
claim to these images
that they don't have.
And that gives you some sense
of the isolation of this place,
where-- they're in the world.
It's a bit like Zen Buddhism.
They're in the world,
but not of the world.
They're a product of
it, but they're not
participating in it fully.
And they're kind of orphaned
in this limbo world.
So I've tried to give you a
brief portrait of the place
and some of the stories.
There are eight other stories.
I've given you one.
There are eight
other characters,
people in this book.
And I'd just like to
pose some questions,
to Google in particular,
but also to us,
as people who don't
live in a refugee camp.
Who participate in the
society of rich countries,
let's call it.
What does this mean for us, and
why should we think about it?
Firstly, I think it's important
to realize this is not
a European refugee crisis.
I was quite surprised
to see how it's always
represented in the American
media as a European refugee
crisis.
Whereas in Europe,
we see the newspapers
and it's the global
refugee crisis.
Of course, everybody's very
self-- very egocentric,
and that's how countries
like to see these stories.
But it's important, I
think, to understand it
as a global refugee crisis.
Partly because, as I said,
it's about this refugee quota
pipeline, the refugee
system that's broken.
Which is why people
are going to Europe.
They're only going to Europe,
because Europe's closer,
and Europe's cheaper.
Those who have
money are actually
paying twice the amount--
it's about $10,000
to go from Somalia to Europe--
to go to the United States.
The illegal route, via
Angola or South Africa,
into Latin America and
out through Mexico,
is around $20,000, $25,000.
But that is a route that
is growing, that people
are increasingly choosing.
Plus, the United States,
Canada, other rich countries,
have a responsibility--
have UN responsibilities--
to share this burden.
And they're not
doing that, which
is why this pipeline is
blocked, and why people
are choosing to go to Europe.
The other reason people are
choosing to go to Europe
is because the
Syrians are learning
from the Somali experience
that a refugee camp is not
a temporary thing.
They know, if we go there,
we're going to be stuck there.
And they're therefore choosing
to go the illegal route.
So in order to stay
in a refugee camp,
in order to keep
people there, they've
got to have some kind of
hope that that place is
going to be useful for them.
Either that they
can gain some skills
and experience while they wait,
or that it might be a departure
lounge for somewhere else.
And in the absence
of any kind of hope,
these individuals
manufacture their own hope,
which is partly what Guled's
Facebook is about and partly
what the book is also about.
So understanding it as a global
refugee crisis is important.
And I think for corporations
like Google to understand
is that we're now at 60 million
globally displaced people.
That's the same as the
population of Great Britain.
And it's the fastest growing
population on the earth.
If it was a country, it would
be a country the size of the UK
that's growing faster
than any other.
Because of the numbers of
people being displaced,
and because of the birth
rate in these camps.
The birth rate in
Dadaab is 1,000 a month.
Now the US, to give you
some kind of perspective,
takes around 1,000 people
from Dadaab every year
for resettlement.
There's no way-- the
UK takes around 100.
Sweden takes around
60-- there's no way
that that number is going
to go down while the camp is
reproducing as it is.
So globally,
collectively, we're all
going to have to bite
that bullet at some point.
Because the numbers of people
in these protracted refugee
situations are
growing and growing.
These cities in limbo
are growing and growing.
Of themselves, but also because
of these crises which don't get
solved-- Central
African Republic,
Sudan, Syria, Iraq, and so on.
You've still got a
million people in Pakistan
from Afghanistan, from
all of those wars, that
are not going home.
So this limbo situation is one
that we need to understand.
And I think we
should think about,
both as a problem--
something which
global citizens and
global corporate citizens
have a responsibility to try
and think about-- and also
as an opportunity.
Mark Zuckerberg
promised to connect
all refugee camps in the world
within, I think, 10 years.
Something like that.
He set a deadline.
And I think that
ambition is admirable.
I think it's great that
these communities should
be connected.
They need to be connected.
We need to somehow have a
way of relating to them.
They need to be integrated
into society, and also
into the economy.
But what do you do
with that connectivity?
That's the question.
Because for the
moment, Facebook mostly
is just a wind-up
for these people.
They're looking at all these
images that they can't have.
They're being told about
these lifestyles that
are unavailable to them.
And it's really a
source of depression.
There's a word-- there's
a guy in the book who
talks about this thing called
Buufis, which is actually
a condition that was
coined in the refugee camp.
It means a longing
for another life.
So you're kind of stuck in this
melancholy situation, where
you don't like your
own life, but you're
wishing for another one.
So the connectivity,
in some senses,
can contribute to
mental illness.
On the other hand, it could
contribute to some positives
for those people.
And this is where I think
it would be good for Google
to think about a
couple of things.
One of them is how do you start
incorporating those cities
in limbo with each other?
And how do you start
incorporating them
with the countries where
they're actually located?
Because these guys have almost
no relationship to Kenya,
apart from through the
truncheons of the Kenya police.
And then, how do you
start incorporating
those populations,
connecting those populations
with the rest of us, in
the rest of the world?
In Kenya, they're
forbidden to work.
But in Jordan, they're not.
In Pakistan, they're not.
These are captive
populations of young people
who would seize any opportunity
with an incredible amount
of zeal.
So they are in the process of
doing online degrees, diplomas,
things like that.
There are some pilot projects,
where people in the refugee
camps are being employed.
They're being
outsourced to do jobs.
Something that I
thought about that I've
talked about with some
people in the camp
is trying to learn how to code.
Trying to learn
programming, so that they
could build basic software and
platforms within the camp that
might make camp life better.
That might solve
some of the problems
that they have in the camp.
That they could then use
that language or those tools
to adapt to their own situation.
Another issue is language.
Google Translate has been very
useful to a lot of the refugees
on that journey from Syria
and from sub-Saharan Africa
over into Europe.
But the European languages
are not-- in the camp,
the European languages
are not what they need.
You need Google
Translate for Somali.
You need Google Translate
for Eritrean, for Amharic,
for Oromo.
For all of these other
languages that people
are speaking in
the Horn of Africa.
And that would be massively
useful to those guys.
The last thing is Street Map.
Street View, even.
Not only would it just be
really interesting to see
what the camp looks like.
But I can foresee all
sorts of applications
for that kind of mapping.
That kind of very, very
specific imagery and specific
GPS positioning, which could
be very useful for policing,
for issues that they have
around sexual violence,
around pinpointing
water problems.
All sorts of stuff where that
kind of mapping technology
could be very useful.
I'm sure you guys could think
of all sorts of other things,
based on all the
specialisms that you
do that I don't know about which
may be useful to this place.
But hopefully my role,
by just giving you
a flavor of this limbo of these
people who are stuck there,
and how the camp-- at least
a brief idea about how
this camp works, and what
it's like to live there--
you can imagine how that might
be relevant to your work.
Or how your work might
be relevant to that.
And the last point
I'd like to finish on
is that these numbers
are only going to grow.
And there's been some discussion
in the UK about climate change.
Perhaps more than here.
I don't know.
But the numbers that we're
seeing displaced by war
are going to be peanuts compared
to the numbers of people that
are going to be on the move
when whole swaths of countries
become uninhabitable.
And that's not that far away.
That's maybe 20 years, 40 years.
Certainly within our lifetimes.
Large numbers of people are
going to be moving, especially
from these parts of the world.
From sub-Saharan Africa, where
it's already too hot, really,
some parts of the year.
And it's getting hotter.
And El Nino this year is
then making it wetter.
So areas that have been
completely deforested
are incredibly hot
in the dry season,
and then literally
floating in the wet season.
We're going to see more and
more of those kinds of climate
refugees.
And that is a lot more general,
and a lot less specific
than war.
So we're going to need to
fix this global refugee
system that doesn't work.
And we're going
to need to come up
with all sorts of
innovative solutions,
including technological
ones, that deal
with temporary cities, and that
deal with temporary societies.
And connect people despite
all of these ideas of race,
and nationality, and so on.
All this nonsense
that divides us.
Let me stop there, and let me
invite questions from anybody.
Thank you.
Some here.
AUDIENCE: Is there any history
of successfully converting
refugee camps into permanent,
functional cities that
are healthy?
I guess by default,
in this case,
it would mean Kenya takes
all the refugees as Kenyans.
But are there smaller instances
that have actually successfully
made that transition.
So it's not about getting
out, but making the camp
into a proper place to live.
BEN RAWLENCE: Yeah.
There are.
Sometimes it's happened
sort of de facto,
just because this place
has been there so long.
So there's a town called
Kassala in southern Sudan
which has been there
for about 50 years now.
And it's still predominantly
a refugee population
of Eritreans.
But it's become its
own city, more or less.
Dadaab is going that way.
You have Gaza.
You have the camps in Lebanon
in Beirut, which are now
pretty much suburbs of Beirut.
You have the West
Bank, of course.
But the Palestinian situation
is sort of specific.
But it's becoming the rule.
It's becoming the norm.
It was supposed to be
a kind of exception,
but actually that's
the way it's going.
You do have examples
of-- there's
a town, I forget the
name, in Belgium--
that after World War
II was a refugee camp.
And it was leased
from a university.
And they took over
the buildings,
and it sort of grew and
grew and grew and grew.
And the town council,
then, took on the mandate
of improving the-- I think the
university invested in the town
and made the town,
grew the town.
And then eventually,
after like 50 years
there was a lease process,
that they handed the town back
to the city council.
And then the city
council took it on again.
So there are some
legal precedents
for doing things like that.
The main problem is not
so much the precedents
in the legal situation.
The problem is the prejudice
of the Kenyan government.
The Kenyan government
doesn't want this place
to become permanent,
because it doesn't
want 400,000, half
a million Somalis,
getting Kenyan citizenship.
So what you have to
try and work with is
acknowledge those fears, as
illegitimate as they may be.
And as illegal as they may be,
because if people seek asylum,
you have to grant
them citizenship
after a period of time.
And that is the law.
That is international law.
But most countries flout that.
So you have to
acknowledge that fear,
and then you have
to try and work
with the Kenyan government.
And say, well, maybe
actually here there
might be something to
benefit you in the end.
And I can foresee
a model where you
had open cities that
were run by the UN, where
if you did insist on controlling
population movements,
you could do that.
But at the same time, you
could invest in the place.
You could make it a
humane place to live,
where there wasn't
disease, and hunger,
and all of these problems.
And possibly where people
could move between them.
OK, you don't want refugees
to come into Kenya.
Fine.
But maybe they can
get on the plane,
and they can go to Mogadishu.
And then they can take
a flight to the UK.
And they can visit
the UK with a visa.
And then they can go home again.
You know, if that home
is not so terrible.
You know?
Then you're subject to
the normal visa regime.
But I mean that's a
big leap of overcoming
an awful lot of
xenophobia and racism
that we currently live with.
OK.
Sorry.
One, two, three.
I'm just making a note.
So I start with the back
and then come to you.
AUDIENCE: And if you
could repeat the questions
for the audience.
BEN RAWLENCE: OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I guess you talked
about xenophobia and prejudice
and absorbing these
large populations.
But I think there's
also the issue
that a lot of world
strife happens
because we get a
political boundary that
doesn't match the cultural
boundaries within it.
So I think it's one
thing to say, well,
we'll take some
stream of refugees
that we can incorporate
into our society.
It's a very
different one to say,
we'll take 500,000
people en masse,
which are then going to
potentially over time
become a destabilizing factor.
So I guess I'm-- of course,
this is a horrible [INAUDIBLE].
BEN RAWLENCE: Mmm.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
saying that seems to meet
a lot of extra [INAUDIBLE].
BEN RAWLENCE: Yes.
The question was about the
borders that don't necessarily
match cultural borders.
And you may have communities
that exist in one state,
but may have affinity
with another.
I mean, you're right.
The Kenyans' government is
in a difficult position.
An unenviable position.
It's very hard for them.
If there were half a million
Scottish people in England,
and Scotland was a
separate country,
and we didn't trust
them, and you know.
I'm sure there would be all
of those sorts of issues.
The point about the
border is correct.
That there's a-- as I
deal with in the book.
In fact, the border should
have been about 200 miles
further south, because that
population of northern Kenya
was historically Somali.
And they wanted to join Somalia,
and the British said, no.
We're going to give it to Kenya.
So one of the guys in the
book, Tawane-- his grandparents
grazed camels on that land
where the refugee camp now is.
And he's a refugee.
But actually, historically
it's his land.
So you know, British colonialism
has a big can to carry.
And so do other countries.
It is difficult.
But that's not to say that
we shouldn't try and overcome
those things.
And we need to find
ways of incorporating
these populations.
Like I said, there are
going to be more of them.
So our idea of the
nation state might
need to shift a little bit.
These myths of nationhood
are always pernicious
and have long lasting effects.
But we now actually have
quite utilitarian reasons
for unlocking them a little bit.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So are things better
or worse now than before?
It seems like there's an
unprecedented refugee crisis,
or it feels that
way, but is that just
because people are surviving
now when they never
would have before?
500 years ago--
war is nothing new,
so there's always
been really bad wars.
But I seem like
500 years ago, you
would have like, millions of
people displaced in the war.
And then they
would just all die.
There was no UN
giving them food.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BEN RAWLENCE: I mean, I don't
know enough about history
to compare over the
course of many years.
I mean, there were massive
population displacements
in World War II.
That was the last time,
certainly, in Europe.
And in East Asia, there
were big, big population
displacements.
When people say that we are in
the midst of a global refugee
crisis now, and they talk
about the figure of 60 million,
that is the largest
since World War II.
Because in World War II,
I'm not sure of the numbers,
but it was probably up there.
But what happened then was
you had borders being redrawn,
because of these refugees.
I think two million people
UNHCR resettled in Europe,
moving them around.
Is Europe and the United
States and other countries--
are we now moving
two million people?
Are we accepting them
from other countries?
Germany has taken,
what, 800,000?
Which is unprecedented.
But they have their
own political reasons
for doing that.
It's great.
But they are suffering from
a declining population.
They have labor shortages.
There is a big
political constituency
to accept those
people in Germany,
which other countries
in Europe don't have.
So we need a Marshall
Plan for dealing
with the current crisis.
It hasn't come out of nowhere.
It has a long-- as I said, it's
been building for a long time.
What's interesting,
or what's new,
is the fact that only now
are we waking up to the fact
that there are all these
people who are displaced.
And the only reason we've
woken up to it in the West
is because they've
started arriving
on the doorstep of Europe.
That's the only reason
it's in the media.
I've been covering
refugee issues
for 10 years with
Human Rights Watch.
There's been thousands of people
dying in the Mediterranean
since 2000-- since 9/11.
Even before.
But it was never really a
news story, because it's
300 dead Africans in a boat.
All of a sudden, it's
300 Africans in a boat,
but hang on.
There's a million who
are actually making it.
And now that's the story.
So what's new is not the
refugee crisis as much
as the perception of it.
The numbers are
rising, but they've
been rising for a long time.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Two questions-- well,
one statement, one question.
I vaguely remember
reading at some point
that there was the
mapping of slums.
I don't know if it was-- it's
most probably a NGO that used
Google technology to do that.
But I remember they had used
local people in the slums
to actually start mapping it.
And then it was useful both
to track the expansion of it
but also useful for the
local population to see.
[INAUDIBLE] explain,
well, there's food here,
and there's this there.
Second question
to you is, do you
know if there is a plan
for those huge movements
of population at some
point when there's going
to be environmental problems?
Or are there plans for that yet?
Are people talking
about it actively?
BEN RAWLENCE: First,
there are two questions.
So first one was about an NGO
that used Google technology
to map slums.
And the second question
was about whether or not
there are forward plans for
thinking about the refugee
consequences of global warming.
The first question, I
know of an NGO in Nairobi
called Spatial Collective,
who are-- shout out.
They're a fantastic
organization.
And they've done this
mapping of slums in Nairobi.
It would be great to see
that rolled out elsewhere,
to see them partner with
other, bigger organizations.
And it's had very material
improvements in people's lives
in terms of their
access to services,
knowing what's going
on, that kind of thing.
Because information
is the first casualty.
And in a situation like that,
where the rumor is everything,
and you hear that the
UN canceled rations.
And all of a sudden, everybody
is saying that actually--
or the UN's cut rations
by 30% and the rumor
is that the UN stopped
getting food altogether,
and they want us to starve.
So getting good
information is key.
The second point.
Now, we're talking in terms
of global warming refugees.
We're talking decades
down the line.
I wouldn't be surprised if
the CIA and MI6 and NASA
are starting to think about it.
I wouldn't be surprised at all.
I haven't seen those plans.
I'm pretty sure that
in some of the disaster
planning for climate change
that that's been talked about.
There's a renegade
scientist in the UK called
James Lovelock who has
talked about how the UK needs
to prepare for big numbers of
refugees from mainland Europe.
Because large parts
of southern Europe
are going to become
too hot, and people are
going to start moving north.
It's something we need
to start thinking about.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm just
curious about UN funding
in general, as this
refugee crisis grows.
Does the UN see
themselves as responsible
to ensure that these refugees
do not actually starve?
And have you seen
any additional policy
being made, more
in the recent days,
in terms of how
to deal with this?
And this is something that
every country's responsible for,
not where this refugee problem's
happening at any given time.
BEN RAWLENCE: Yeah.
The question is about UN
funding and whether there's
been an increase in the response
to stop people starving.
There has been an increase.
But I mean, the
way that it works
is that the UN is the
collective embodiment of all
of the members.
And the member states are
the UK, my country, the US,
all the other
countries of the world.
There are standing
contributions to the UN,
and then there are
emergency contributions
whenever there's a problem.
So UNHCR, the UN Refugee
Agency, has a kind of budget
that it draws down
from the general part.
But that's not enough.
Which is why refugees
in Dadaab are having
their rations cut by 30%.
And earlier in
the year, refugees
in all of the Syrian camps also
had their rations cut by 30%.
Because the UN could
not feed everybody.
So it seems to me
that-- and the way
to fill that gap is for rich
governments to plug the hole.
So I know that the British
government, for example,
made extra donations
to the Syrian refugees,
but nobody gave
money to the Somalis.
Because they're forgotten
about, and they're not on the TV
screens.
And in this world of
imperfect democracy,
unfortunately
what's on television
is how the politicians respond.
So in my view, all of
the nation-- all of us,
who are citizens of
our nation states--
need to make sure that
our nation states remember
everybody.
And at the minimum
feed these people.
You can't put them
in a refugee camp,
forbid them from leaving
the refugee camp,
and then not feed them.
That's a crime on-- to me,
that's almost a war crime.
That's a crime against humanity,
forcing people to starve.
And people are dying.
I'll take both questions and
try and answer them together.
Could you go ahead?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Do you have insight into what
the standard infrastructure
for a camp is?
So let's say, if
the UN shows up.
They set up tents, for sure.
But then, what about water,
communication, et cetera,
et cetera?
BEN RAWLENCE: OK.
And the other question?
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if you could
talk about the motivation for
disallowing work [INAUDIBLE].
BEN RAWLENCE: Is that a hand?
No.
OK.
The two questions.
The first one was about
the infrastructure
of a refugee camp.
What that looks like.
How it works.
And I suppose relatedly,
the second question
was about the motivation for not
allowing the refugees to work.
The refugee camp model is
something that's a little bit
outdated.
It was something that the
UN did a lot in the 1990s,
when a host government had
a big refugee population
and they couldn't cope.
Like with Bosnia, with
Kosovo, with Rwanda.
So Tanzania would say to
the UN, we can't cope.
We need you to come
and set up camps.
We don't want to
allow that population
to integrate into our society.
We want you to
put them in camps.
Technically, it's illegal.
You're supposed to allow
refugees freedom of movement.
But what happens
is the governments
find a way around it by
requiring movement policies.
A bit like apartheid
in South Africa,
where you were in a camp.
It's like a Bantustan.
You need a pass to come out
and join the rest of the world.
So they find these funny
ways of trying to regulate it
and arguing that it's
legal, but it's not.
But still, in
fast-moving emergencies,
the UN-- that is the only way
that you can look after people.
If you've got 50,000
people who have just
run from a town in South
Sudan which is burning,
and they need food
and shelter and so on,
a camp-- a temporary
city-- is the only way
that you're going
to look after them.
And then over time, of
course, they become permanent.
But what that is is, yes,
as you say, it's tents.
It's mobile hospitals
to start with,
which then become permanent.
Over time, it's schools.
Often boreholes to
bring the water in,
or you're trucking water in.
And then it's food.
So in Dadaab, you still have
an emergency feeding situation,
where you're shipping 8,000 tons
of food a month-- most of that
from the United States, because
the US gives food aid in kind.
It doesn't give cash to
the UN for its own reasons.
Because that's helpful.
So that food aid
has to be shipped.
Has to come up.
Travel three days by truck
into the middle of the desert
in order to feed everybody.
Your transportation costs
are about four times the cost
of the actual food.
If only we could
give them the money.
But that is part
of US government's
political decisions about
how it meets its obligations
and also benefits
its own citizens.
There are all sorts
of contradictions
in keeping these things going.
So that's the infrastructure.
And after 25 years, or
40 years, or 50 years,
some of those things have
evolved and some of those
haven't.
The prohibition on
work is because it's
an age-old narrative.
In Britain, there's this
common political epithet.
We don't want them
taking our jobs.
There's this assumption
that immigrants and refugees
take jobs from nationals.
Generally, all the
economic evidence
is that people create
more wealth and more jobs
than they take.
But for the
right-wing xenophobes,
that's an easy play to make.
And Kenya believes very much--
to answer the second question--
Kenya believes very much
that these refugees present
a threat to the economic
prospects of Kenyans.
Even though that's not the case.
It's a politically
useful story to tell
when you, as a politician,
are facing pressure
for why you haven't generated
any economic opportunities
for your people.
Especially in an area
like northern Kenya,
which is very marginalized.
A lot of corruption.
Leaders who, I
would say, haven't
done their people very proud.
Have not really looked
after their populations.
It's very easy to blame all
the problems on the refugees.
I probably got time
for one more, maybe,
or two more questions.
Are there any?
Some here.
AUDIENCE: So it seems
like maybe we're
making the presumption of
more health than there is.
But there is a huge amount
of work to be done in a camp,
right?
Just taking garbage and
sewage out from the latrines
or living areas elsewhere.
God knows where.
Any sort of cleaning.
Any sort of movement
of material.
Does the work just not happen?
Or is work within the
camp considered OK?
Is there an organization
of labor within the camp?
BEN RAWLENCE:
Well, increasingly,
what's happening as the
budget is going down and down,
and the UN can't manage on
its own, what's happening
is it's enlisting the refugees
as volunteers to run the camp.
Now, on some level that's good.
But on another level, you're
asking refugees sometimes
to do technical
jobs, like teaching,
like being water engineers,
like being sanitation engineers.
And you're asking them to do it
without the proper equipment,
without the proper support.
So what happened recently was
that there was no sanitation.
The UN just cut the budget.
Said we're not paying for people
to collect rubbish anymore.
And it just piled
up in the streets.
And the sewage was everywhere.
I mean, it's bad anyway,
but it got even worse.
So the refugees
organized themselves.
Because of the
prohibition on work,
they're not allowed to be
paid like Kenyan workers.
So instead they volunteer,
and they get paid a stipend.
The stipend is
about $70 a month.
So often, because you can't
get enough Kenyan teachers
to go into the schools to
teach the people in the city,
you're enlisting refugee
teachers who are working.
They're not trained.
They're working as
primary school teachers,
secondary school teachers, even.
And they're being
paid $70 a month.
And they're next
to a Kenyan teacher
who's being paid by
the Kenyan government
and who is earning $1,000
or one and a half thousand,
or something like that.
So it's incredibly unfair.
The incentives to
volunteer are quite low.
But people do it when the
situation gets too bad.
So it's very badly
organized, really.
Yep.
MALE SPEAKER: Last one.
BEN RAWLENCE: OK, last one.
AUDIENCE: The follow-up to
that question-- and this
may seem very uninformed,
but I'll ask it anyway.
So let's say you do have
a village that flees
and lands in another country.
Do people just continue on their
professions within the camps?
So for example, if there were
teachers in that village,
can they continue or is
there not enough organized--
does the camp organize itself
as it may have been in the past?
BEN RAWLENCE: Yeah,
there's definitely--
the question was
about whether people
continue their old
professions in the camp,
once they move there.
There's definitely
an element of that.
But often, you
can't always find--
there isn't the job to do.
But there certainly is an
element of self-organizing.
What would be great would
be if the refugees were
empowered more to organize
themselves and to run things,
and given the proper support,
and the proper budget,
and the equipment, and so on.
For example, there's a
community police force.
What they want
more than anything
is boots, because you can't get
good shoes in a refugee camp.
Everybody is either
barefoot or in flip flops.
And the other thing they
want is two-way radios.
Because they're all using
their own mobile phones.
And they get given a
little bit of phone credit,
like scratch cards, to
top up their phones.
But often that's not enough,
or it runs out, or whatever.
What they want is two-way radios
so that they can communicate
about their patrolling.
They don't have weapons.
But if there's a problem,
they call the police.
But in order to call
the police, they
have to have a cell
phone with credit on it.
So there's tiny things like
that that if you supported them
properly and allowed them
to do their own thing,
they could make the
camp a better place.
I'll stop there
with the questions.
But on the theme of making
the camp a better place,
I hope that those of you
watching and those of you
here might have some inclination
to think a little bit about how
you might be able to help
make that a better place.
Thanks a lot.